weiß sie dass du youtube macht ist sie
älter oder jünger ist die haben sich
deine eindruck von ihr seit dem ersten
treffen geändert würdet ihr mal ein
video zusammen machen also will sie das
kommt so neuen videokonsolen video das
entstanden ist weil er mich auch ins
programm ausgiebig therapiert habt und
h&h kann
leute seid leben dieses thema existiert
mit dem mädchen das in seattle an meine
tür gehängt hat und seitdem ich
durchgemacht gut 90 ganz natürlich ist
das ein thema was ich extrem
interessiert kennt fast jeden tag auf
ganz umgängliche anfangen wie läuft's
nicht habt ihr irgendwas hat mir nichts
mehr und deswegen angesagt heute mache
ich hab mein knie video dazu bevor es
losging heute für alle die sich fragen
wieder vorüber redest du gerade es geht
um eine geschichte aus meinem
persönlichen leben vor wurde zwei
monaten hat eine fremde person mir ein
set an meine tür gehängt mit einem
lieben spruch unter der nummer drunter
und sie persönlich kennengelernt und
dayton sie mit allerdings die personen
weiter wissen und genau darin sieht
dieses video und wenn wir heute alle
fragen klären
max hat man instagram hat die fragen die
mir gestellt hatten ist jetzt suchen wir
ist auch direkt die erste frage mal raus
weiß sie dass du youtube macht das weiß
sie mittlerweile also helfen sie aber
schon eine ganze weile jetzt also seit
anfang mai und dann spricht man ja auch
bei sie bei fast alles in der bild
zeitung hat sich auch erfahren dass ich
mitmache ansprechen also miteinander das
ist ja auch klar sie hat was ich meine
also ja wie kann es noch mal dass diese
erfahren hat ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher wie das ist doch schon mal
erzählt aber das ganze lief
folgendermaßen es war eines der ersten
date und auf einmal mitten drin wir
hatten wie so was zu essen geholt hast
du irgendwo so haben entspannung noch
ein bisschen geschockt auf einmal kommen
sie zu mir
um also die basis von formular meint
also zu mir willst mir nicht erzählen
nicht so dinger ich weiß nicht was es
ist aber ich weiß nicht ob's genommen
und dann herausgestellt dass irgendwie
ein freund von der freude für jedes
video gesehen hatte dass man sich so
weitergegeben hat und ich hatte schon
über über strecken gemacht nämlich ohne
dass ich sie gesagt hat und ja ihr könnt
aber wir haben sie nach unten es auf
jeden fall eine feine geschichte und ich
dachte mir auch in videos darüber zu
machen was ich aber es ist ja scheinbar
ganz gut ausgang wer war es nächste
frage lautet nämlich habt ihr geheiratet
selbstverständlich ganz ehrlich ich
hatte mich auch ab dass hier so
offensichtliche frage stellt leute wie
ken uns mittlerweile zwei monate fast 3
an dem punkt oder ebenfalls klasse dass
wir parat 180 kinder in not wie oft habt
ihr euch schon getroffen falls das
überhaupt schon passiert ist das hat ja
schon beantwortet dass ihr euch ja wie
oft ja oft also oft klar ich habe jetzt
keinen account oder so was also sehr oft
dauert dann kommen wir zur nächsten
frage habt ihr schon miteinander
geschlafen ich nicht frage also nicht
millionen auch die nächste phase schon
mal antwortet weil es sie dass die
videos über sie macht mittlerweile ist
sollte mittlerweile weiß sie auch dass
du dieses video über sieht da das ist
richtig sollte also ich habe natürlich
aus meinen fehlern gelernt eine wichtige
sache im leben das man aus den fehlern
die man begeht lernt entlang des eigenen
lebensweges wir jetzt natürlich gefragt
bevor das layout die gemacht haben und
dass jetzt drehe
sie hatte zugegeben endlich schicks hier
sogar noch mal über volkshochschule auf
save und dann ist sie älter oder jünger
ist
gute frage hättest du dich an ihrer
stelle getraut dafür vielleicht noch mal
kurz die anekdote wie ihr euch überhaupt
kennen wie gesagt schon für alle die
also jetzt schon gesagt also die ganze
story hat damit begonnen das sie mir ein
zettel an meine tür gehangen hat unten
ein haus was ich wohl im haus mit
mehreren monaten an die tür zu den
zettel dann gemacht und war sich quasi
gerne sicher erstens dass ich denn
überhaupt bekomme zweitens ob ich
überhaupt verfügbar in also ob ich
single bin hat sie trotzdem traut ihr
das gemacht so realistisch never ever
ja so kann es auch gehen wie findet sie
dass do you tube machst koller auch
keine ahnung also interessante frage
auch aber ich glaube ist neutral also
könnte genausogut wahrscheinlichkeit
versicherungen verkaufen oder nie dann
wird besonders gut ich könnte keine
autos verkaufen oder sonstwo arbeitet
das glaubt ihr ganzes spiel cavalcante
sie sich schon vorher bzw wusste sie wer
du bist nein also das nicht zwischendrin
hat sie so angefangen weil mein kopf
videos mir zu reden
ja das ist aber normal ist der job heute
dann kann das nicht wie haben sich deine
eindruck von ihr seit dem ersten treffen
geändert positiv sehr positiv geworden
und sich dann auf jeden fall am anfang
war ich halt jetzt sehr gut dann nehme
ich halt mit chris videos soll
nein also aber es ist noch besser weil
sie sich sehr gut
ich gratuliere würdet ihr mal ein video
zusammen machen also will sie das habe
ich tatsächlich schon vorgeschlagen aber
ist nicht so ist nicht zu bekommen ist
sich zu machen kann ich gut verstehen
leute man muss aber auch sagen also
alleine auch schon dass dieses videos
ist die macht ist schon sehr sehr eng
mit dabei muss man sagen ja die
allermeisten leute trauen sich nicht so
dieses level an privatsphäre die
öffentlichkeit auf zu transportieren bei
mir ist es also in dem fall weiter hat
sich etwas ergeben
aber ja aber man muss es ja uns bis zum
allerletzten punkt ausreizen finde ich
war der kleine hund von ihr in deinen
story
das ist ja das hat sich der alle sie hat
einen kleinen hunden kein bauer und der
gespräche mit der man die meines tores
zu sehen weil dann sind das haben jetzt
zusammen dass ich gerne mit ihrer zeit
verbracht habe also ich habe über wochen
oder irgend sowas also kannst du mit ihr
öffnen und ehrlich reden kann es mit dem
öffnen also erst mal machen wir haben
die fragen stellen hier kannst du mit
ihr rechnen so eine flasche wein ich
habe schon eine für sie geöffnet
ehrlich reden kennt sie schon dein
bruder würde mich auch mal ja ja ja ja
auch das schon super getroffen da ja
sicher und damit kommen auch schon zur
letzten frage und zwar würdest du sie
noch näher kennenlernen also ja es
selbstverständlich verständlicher doch
auf jeden fall also meine sonst müssen
wir ja auch nicht teil miteinander
verbringen gerne 200 das was von dem
appell für euch heute ich hoffe aber
fragen sind jetzt beantwortet max und
dann schauen wir verlinkt gefällt hier
einfach vorgestellt das video jungen
könnt ihr meinen kanal abonnieren ich
werde mich so schnell raus bleibt stabil
und macht ja